we're starting our day we need to go
rent a light because we're gonna go
cave-dwelling today and I'm pretty
pumped
are you excited because I want to find
out John look at this light go stand
next to it wait a minute wait wait a
minute it was like a cave like like a
cave like you walk into it alright so I
dropped my light I haven't even gotten
to the hole yet but I see the light so
that's a good thing okay I realize cave
crawling was literally crawling so you
in okay so I just booty crawled back
into this game jenna is now on her way
down
my camera's wet I am not sorry yeah I
did it
you look great you look great thank you
exactly oh my gosh I can't believe
there's a light panel already here
waiting for us this is amazing can you
see Jeff yeah I can't even see you yeah
no it's beautiful okay alright
yes our exploring bit wordy cave
we made it down in this cave this is
actually the coolest thing that well I
said that every single time I like this
look cool things every day I know but
everything is so cool it's like camping
it's really cool
so we basically went down a hole and
there's a cave I mean this is actual
cave crawling
my butt's muddy why did you show me oh
yeah we this one chief is launching so
thank you guys so much for watching I
had so much fun doing the project mini a
project did you have fun I have yes I
mean my Instagram pictures on point that
insta go oh my gosh oh okay oh I didn't
realize this was the hole going up go up
just a lot of blood action Oh where's my
upper-body strength not existing